Hitler Grüße vor Disney World eine
Demonstration amerikanischer Neonazis in
Orlando Florida neben Hakenkreuzen
Banner des republikanischen
Präsidentschaftskandidaten Ron
deent eine Flagge mit jugudendstern
verdeckt Mickey Maus pädophilenwelt
steht
darauf ausgerechnet in seinem Hund
Jubiläumsjahr ist Micky Maus ins Visier
rechter kulturkämpfer
denn Disney will divers und inklusiv
werden zuletzt sorgte eine Werbung für
die Disney Kollektion in den sozialen
Medien für Empörung der influenzer
bezeichnet sich selbst als
genderfuid zuerst haben sie Männern
erlaubt sich in den Vergnügungsparks als
Prinzessinnen zu verkleiden dann sich
als Frauen zu verkleiden und Kleidung an
kleine Mädchen zu verkaufen dann
kreierten sie
ein jetzt arbeiten sie mit Sean alman
zusammen er bezeichnet sich als gender
Fluid trägt aber das Pronomen eher ihm
so indoktrinieren sie
Kinder er schürt den Hass auf Disney Ron
des santus per Gesetz hatte der
Gouverneur von Florida Schulen verboten
mit jüngeren Kindern über sexuelle
Identität zu sprechen nach Protesten der
queeren Community hatte sich die Disney
Führung bei des sentes über sein
sogenanntes don't say gay Gesetz
beschwert
seitdem wirft er Disney vor dass sie
einer woken Agenda Folgen Anfang des
Jahres entzog er die jahrzehntelangen
Sonderrechte über das Gelände von Disney
World in Florida werde alles sterben was
woke sei droht sentes in einer Talkshow
ri er Disney sich auf seine Kernaufgabe
zu
konzentrieren das ist ein Kader wer
Manager in Burbank die versuchen diese
Agenda dem Rest des Unternehmens
aufzuzwingen das ist katastrophal mein
Rat was Disney unter Wal zu einer
amerikanischen Firma gemacht hat war der
Fokus auf die Familie auf traditionelle
proamerikanische Werte sie wären nie auf
die Idee gekommen Kinder zu
sexualisieren unterdessen feiert der
größte Unterhaltungskonzern der Welt 100
geburtstag mit einer Jubiläumsschau in
London über desentes Kulturkampf will
niemand bei Disney mit Kulturzeit
sprechen unsere Interviewanfragen
gelehnt seit 100 Jahren prägen die
fantasievollen Welten der Disneyfilme
unsere Kindheitsträume der Schöpfer
dieses Imperiums Walt Disney vor allem
sein Name war schon immer weltweit
gerarant für kinderfreundliche
Produkte er selbst sah es etwas anders
nicht Kinderfilme wollte er drehen
sondern Filme für das Kind in uns 1901
hineingeboren in eine amerikanische
Durchschnittsfamilie seine Kindheit
findet kaum statt schon als Neunjähriger
muss er für seinen Vater einen
Kleinunternehmer schuften zeichnen ist
für Walt Disney frühventil um seine
Kindheit
zurückzuholen mit Steamboat Willy dreht
er seinen ersten Zeichentrickfilm mit
Ton Mickey Maus debütiert als pfeifende
trickfilmfigur Kritiker und Publikum
sind verzückt die Maus ist tollkühn ihr
Humor eher derb ein Underdog gesprochen
von Walt Disney selbst wer ihn versteht
[Musik]
miehen ich sehe Walt Disney als eine
aufsteigerfigur aus kleinsten
Verhältnissen der vor allen Dingen einen
Lieblingsschauspieler hatte das war J
Chaplin und Mickey Maus agiert wie J
Chaplin in diesen frühen Film das ist
der underdg der mit ganz vielen Tricks
es schafft immer auf der Oberseite zu
sein die Maus und der amerikanische
Traum mitten in der Weltwirtschaftskrise
1929 stet miy z st auf und ist
allgegenwärtig schon 1932 hat der Mickey
mus Fanclub 1 Million Mitglieder mit der
Maus wird auch Walt Disney weltberühmt
für sie sammelt er seine ersten Oscars
ein dutzende werden folgen die
Vermarktung von Mickey Maus und ander
Disney Figuren spüt Geld viel Geld in
die oft klammen Kassen es fließt gleich
in die nächsten
Filmprojekte
dies
die abendfüllende zeichentrickfil ein
Meilenstein fürs Kino Walt Disneys
Vision eine echte Geschichte erzählen
ein Märchen mit Drama seine Zwerge haben
deutlich mehr Herz und Charakter als in
den grimschen
[Musik]
Märchen Musik ein Schlüsselelement und
wegweisend für alle künftigen zerickf
von
dis alles für den Film auch astronomisch
hohe Kredite Disney hatte eben 1us Leute
nötig um diesen schnchenfilm zu machen
und das war etwas was man nie
ausprobiert hatte können Leute das
aushalten Z lange Animation anzugucken
und ob Schneewitchen wird weltweit zum
erfolgreichsten Tonfilm seiner
Zeit alle trickzeichner kamen zur
Weltpremiere weil sie sehen wollten wie
das Publikum reagieren würde doch als
die Zuschauer weinten wussten sie alles
wird
gut Disney bedient große Gefühle aber
auch Stereotypen die kräen in dumo
erinnern an minstral Shows des 19
Jahrhundert in denen Schauspieler mit
geschwzten Gesichtern Sklaven verhünten
der Chef der krän heißt Jim Crow genau
wie die rassistischen Bühnenfiguren
damals Disney plus zeigt dambo heute nur
noch mit einer Warnung vor negativen
Stereotypen der Film song of the south
stellt people of color als unbekümmerte
Farmarbeiter dar die sich glücklich
wähnen für die weißen Besitzer zu
arbeiten lange nach dem Ende der
Sklaverei dieser Film ist im Giftschrank
gelandet laut Disney Management passt er
nicht mehr in die heutige Welt doch
schon
1946 gab es
Proteste song of the south wird in der
Disney Ausstellung nicht thematisiert
trotz Oscar für die beste
Musik die dunklen Seiten Disneys in
London bleiben sie
ausgespartt
s the south war ein Produkt seiner Zeit
aber was 1946 zur Zeit des Release noch
akzeptabel war passt heute nicht mehr so
sehr wir konnten hier einfach nicht
alles unterbringen diese Ausstellung ist
eine Feier von 100 Jahren
Disney das heute nicht Stereotypen
sondern Diversität in Canon prägt dafür
sorgt seit 2020 die Initiative Stories
matter reimagine tomorrow das neue
Mantra von Disney
wir sind gewachsen haben uns verändert
indem wir neue Geschichten auf neue
Weise erzählen uns ist wichtig dass das
was wir verkaufen oder erschaffen
weltweit zugänglich ist für alle
Menschen doch für den
Kommunikationswissenschaftler Peter
Kunze geht es hier nicht um eine
progressive Agenda sondern um neue
Märkte für
disneypukte in Wirklichkeit steht hinter
der Idee der wokeness bei Disney der
Kapitalismus
sie versuchen den Markt so weit wie
möglich auszudehnen das Unternehmen hat
sich in seiner Geschichte unpolitisch
gegeben dabei aber konservative
Familienwerte hochgehalten und
Stereotypen reproduziert die viele als
ein niedrigend und einmschlichend
empfinden dass Disney nun als Prediger
progressiver Politik und wokeness
angesehen wird ist gelinde gesagt
ziemlich
ironisch Walt Disney inszenierte sich
als unpolitischer Geschichtenerzähler
doch er verstand es die Politik für für
seine Zwecke zu nutzen zu Beginn des
Zweiten Weltkriegs steht das Unternehmen
vor dem Bankrott Disney produziert
zunächst kostenlos Kriegspropaganda
verdient später mit leerrfilmen für das
Militär 1942 sind fast alle Produktionen
an Regierungsaufträge gebunden als seine
Belegschaft 1941 streigt vermutet er
kommunistische
[Musik]
Agitation später nennt er vor dem
mcarthy Ausschuss der Streikführer und
lässt sich so für die damalige
kommunistenjagd
einspannen laut FBI Akten war er
jahrzehnteel lang Special Agent in
charge kurz sac berichtete aus Hollywood
über subversive Personen mit FBI Chef J
edgar Hoover plante Disney Sendungen
durch die Kinder so wörtlich zum FBI
aufschauen würden das FBI nahm sogar
Änderungen an Disney drebüchern vor
[Musik]
Walt Disneys größtes Fantasieprodukt war
Walt Disney die Version von ihm als
Geschäftsmann in seinem Büro der Amerika
anlächelt und sich als oncel Wal mit
einer warmen und authentischen
Aufrichtigkeit präsentiert war ein Bild
das er schuf ähnlich wie seine Filme und
Zeichentrickfilme ähnlich wie die Bilder
die sein Unternehmen noch heute
produziert mit Disneyland in Kalifornien
schuf sich König Wal 1955 sich sein
Reich hier halten die Großen und
Mächtigen der Welt Hof Richard Nixons
Tochter darf die Monorail einweihen alle
Stars des Disney Unternehmens tauchen
wieder auf das Publikum taucht einfach
ab in die reale Nachbildung einer
amerikanischen Scheinwelt Weltflucht für
viele Millionen Besucher jährlich später
folgt Disney World in Florida
Touristenmagnet die Wasserbahn Splash
Mountain mit Figuren aus song of the
south seit diesem Jahr wegen
rassismusvorwürfen geschlossen die
Themenparks wichtigstes Standbein für
Disney das nach dem Tod des Gründers in
eine Sinnkrise geret erst der Broadway
führte Disney in den 80er Jahren aus der
kreativen und finanziellen Krise das
zeigt Peter Kunze in einem neuen Buch
damals strömten kreative vom
Musiktheater zu Disney und erfanden den
Animationsfilm neu die sogenannte Disney
Renaissance zentrale Figur Howard ashman
bekennender Homosexueller Produzent von
erfolgen wie Ariel modernisier igur
selbstbestimmte auenseiter die
akzeptiert werden wollen
Projektionsfläche auch fürere
Menschen mit der klein mejungfrau haben
Sie nicht nur die Tradition der
Märchenprinzessinnen wiederbelebt
sondern auch die Tradition des
integrierten Musicals das heißt sie
haben die Musik genutzt um die
Geschichte zu erzählen und diese Musik
konnte dann auf Alben verkauft in
Themenparks gespielt und am Broadway
aufgeführt werden esbte eine
der Filme im Zentrum standen und deren
Geschichten und Storytelling auf andere
Bereiche des Unternehmens ausgeweitet
wurden ein Erfolgsmodell seit den 30er
Jahren frisches Geld sollen jetzt
Neuauflagen von Klassikern wie Ari
bringen gleiche Geschichte diverse
Charaktere doch eignen sich die Plots
der Vergangenheit um der
derw
Z ist nicht unbedingt eine progressive
Geste die Filme nehmen oft keine
Rücksicht auf deren Geschichte und die
damit verbundenen
Erfahrungen viel mehr werden die
Schauspieler in eine Rolle gesteckt die
wenig darüber aussagt was es wirklich
bedeutet eine Person of color in dieser
Welt zu
sein wenn Ron Disney als W brandmarkt
und das Erbe Walt Disneys in Gefahr
sieht dann irr er disy he passt sich
damals stets dem Zeitgeist an um auch
100 Jahre nach seiner Gründung die Welt
zu verzaubern und ganz nebenbei
Milliarden zu
schen